while marvel films just seems to get
bigger and bigger with every passing
year black panther continues to stand
above its contemporaries
a record-breaking success a pop culture
phenomenon an oscar nominee for best
picture
and a film that shattered barriers
across the world this 2018 superhero
movie was about as artfully designed as
comic book cinema could ever hope to be
black panther packs in enough world
building for an epic fantasy trilogy
introduces dozens of memorable
characters adapts multiple comic book
story arcs and sends the audience home
with a powerful
socially relevant message that can't be
forgotten before black panther was a
finished film though it was a script a
camera and a whole bunch of scenes that
needed to be strung together
editing is one of the most
underappreciated aspects of film
production
in general no matter how good your
material is keeping the pace tight means
being ruthless about which scenes matter
and which don't
hard choices are required in a 2018
press interview director ryan coogler
said that there was one scene in
particular
said in the wake of t'challa's apparent
death that he was quote
incredibly proud of but which he simply
couldn't fit into the film
now coogler talks this scene up for a
reason sat in the wakandan citadel high
above the city it depicts okoye and
wakabe an intense verbal confrontation
over killmonger's takeover of wakanda
which has resulted in t'challa's
apparent death the two of them both
loyal to wakanda above all else are
split in regard to killmonger's goals
aside from the phenomenal acting by both
performers the scene also showcases the
characters as individuals as leaders and
as two
people in a relationship this is what
you would have me leave the daughter for
to bring our children into this world
where they become
conquerors yes in an interview with the
rap black panther editor michael shaver
described this terrific sequence as the
one scene that was the most
heartbreaking to cut from the film he
recalled
toward the end after things go bad and
killmonger is in control and all that
we're talking about what are they going
to do what is wakanda going to become
those are two powerhouse actors and it
was an incredible scene with so many
layers to it
boyfriend and girlfriend it was general
and her advisor all those things
that was painful that said both he and
coogler agreed that it had to go
as shawber put it film editing requires
being hyper aware of moments where the
audience might
lose immersion at that point in the
movie it's about two-thirds through and
that's when most movies drag
ours was taking a while to get to that
point the okoye wakabe scene wasn't the
only great moment to go splat on the
cutting room floor
charver said there's a scene between
t'challa and zuri which sets up their
relationship it sort of lets you attach
yourself to their father-son dynamic so
that later on in the film
you really feel more googler and company
also made the tough decision of cutting
a great emotional beat between t'challa
and his real father to chaka this scene
is a flashback set immediately after the
events in the opener wherein t'chaka
kills killmonger's father in jobu
and it shows to chaka back home in
wakanda telling a younger t'challa of a
difficult choice he just made
but some choices are harder than others
i am sure you did what is right for
rotunda
you always do what a great king baba
the young boy proclaims that when he
grows up and dons the black panther
costume he will use his claws to ensure
that his father never dies
there's a lot of great foreshadowing
here and the scene does help establish
how the roles of king and black panther
aren't quite synonymous
still you can see why it got cut nice or
not there's nothing critical here that
isn't established elsewhere in the film
and deleting the scene allowed the
narrative to get back to the present day
much more rapidly
at a point in the story where pacing is
particularly crucial
either way every movie has to make cuts
and black panther was no different
but coogler and company can take pride
in having such high quality and
emotional resonance even in scenes that
didn't make it to the big screen
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you